ينضم الينا هنا في الستوديو ساميولبرج
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
اهلا بك ااا يعني بعد 20 عام للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه داخل افغانستان همم
خرجت امريكا ويعني عادت افغانستان 100 سنه
الى سنه الى الخلف اااه ما هي اساليب
الضغط التي تملكها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لساني طالبان عن هذه القرارات
حول الادانه الواسيه ليس فقط من الولايات
المتحده ولكن من المجتمع الدولي هذه
القرار على هذه القرار الاخير بالنسبه
النساء الافغانستان همم من عمل في المؤسسه
غير الحكوميه وكل هذه القرارات فعلا تؤدي
الى زياده الاصل همم
من سكان افغانستان اذن همم كما قلت ال-
ال- الان كما نرى في الاذغانستان همم هذا
ليس همم السبب او ليس مسؤوليه للشعب
الافغانيسه ولكن همم للتعلي معنا حركه
طالما هي التي تاخذ كل هذه القرارات همم
الولايات المتحده للدينا بعد الاليات
واسمعنا منذ ايام من وزير ملك ان نحن الان
سنبحث من حلفائنا وشركائنا بالنسبه
رساله واضحه للي تعليمات حول هذه القرارات
طيب هذا يعني كيف بيفيد الافغانيات
والنساء الافغانيات
واي اجراءات التي
مشاكيل او او تهديات امام الشعب الافغاني
او خاصه النساء والفتيات اكثر
من العقوبات ومن همم اليات اخرى ولكن اهم
شيء الان نحن نريد ركز على الوضع في
ادغانستان واخسرا ووضع بالنسبه النساء
والفتيات والا نريد ناخذ اي اجراءات التي
ستؤدي الى ضرار اكثر
اعمال الاغاثه وجمعيات كبرى يعني انجي اوز
كبيره هل هذا يعاقب طالبان اي يعاقب
الافغانيين
بدون شك هذه القرار من طلبان لمنع النساء
باكماله ليس طالبان ونحن همم الان سنبحث
عن الامكانيه لوصول او ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه ولكن فقط ليوم سمعنا من بعد
المؤسسات الانديه المؤسسه غير حكميه انه
ليس من الممكن انهم يستمر في الشغل في
اركان الاسلام
الافغاني من قبل طالبان الان لا تريد
العمل يعني الى اين يؤدي ذلك بالافغانيين
يبدو حتى الان نحن مازال لازم نسمع اكثر
من هذه المؤسسات ولكن هذه المواسسات لا
تاخذ القرار همم اعقاب او عقوبه ضد
الكلمات لا ليس لديها الامكانيه لتستمر في
الشغل في افغانستان بدون اكثر من نصف من
موظفيها لان نحن نعرف ان النساء بشكل عام
كم سمعنا من وزير
من كل المسؤولين الامريكيين اليوم سمعنا
بشكل
العمل الجماعي اكثر واكثر
يعني البعض يلوم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي تلام بعد 20 عام داخل
افغانستان افغانستان تم تسليم افغانستان
لطالبان هيك بليله
وغادرت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونحن
الان بهذه النتيجه